James Harden's a Clipper now so what's
your view of La as a rival in the
Western Conference when you put those
names on paper they'll be as good as any
names you can put together you're
talking four first ballot Hall of Famers
two MVPs one finals MVP a perennial
Allstar you can't put much else better
on paper they're also getting ERS just
like us I think all of those guys are
probably in year 14 or 15 or above Kawai
clayer so it's 13th and so health will
be important as well and even around
those guys you know they still got zubac
they still got Norma P still got bones
High PJ Tucker in on that deal too with
Harden and then they also have an
incredible coaching tyo so they'll be a
team a force to be reckoned with you
hope to get to the end and see everybody
healthy and may the best man win but
they'll be a tough team